こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
皆さんはギャングスター知ってるかな？
まあ僕も詳しいことよく知らないんですけども
アメリカとかではね
お金関係とか銃社会とか
よくわからないんですけども
危険なことには大抵ギャングスターが絡んでるんですよ
で、あ、僕は絡んでないですよ
俺は絡んでないんですけども
今回の動画はですね
この僕がもしね怪しい組織、ギャングスターとかそういう人たちに絡まれてて
今から後輩が僕の家に来るんですけども
後輩が僕の家に来た時に
僕がギャングスターに裏切られちゃって
ギャングスターに僕が拘束されてて
とっても危険な状態のはじめwithギャングスターみたいな感じの状態の時に
後輩が僕の家に来てどういう反応するのかっていうのを確かめてみようと思います
今回ギャングスターはしっかりですね銃とか武装させて
本当に危険な状態で後輩を来させるので
ギャングスターに捕らわれたこの俺様をアイツが救えるかどうかっていうのが今回の見どころとなっております
それではお楽しみに　ではいこう
はじめ：もしもし？
後輩：もしもし？
はじめ：ありがと、着いた？
はじめ：着いた？　後輩：うん
はじめ：OK　じゃあ今開けます
はじめ：なんだお前らおいやめろ！
はじめ：うｐ－うｐ－まさき！
はじめ：一番奥の部屋に来てくれうおおおお
*勇ましい音楽*
ギャング：おいお前金どこに隠したんじゃこの野郎
はじめ：*上手く聞き取れない奇声*
ギャング：おい誰だこの野郎おい
ギャングたちの発狂
おい誰だお前
wwwwwww
まさき：なんなんこれｗ
はじめ：危機感感じなかったの？
まさき：感じなかったｗ
はじめ：なんでー
はじめ：え、待ってなんで？怖くなかった？
はじめ：俺がギャングスターに捕らわれてたんだよ？